talked about this Apple watch business
and what you think about it where is
good and what the numbers are gonna be
like and maybe bigger picture sort of
where you see the the growth there if
any it's early and it's going to right
now the applications are good but
they're they're not the same wow
experience you have with your phone and
use it another iPad is another Apple TV
it's it's ultimately going to be another
iPad hopefully before iPad had its kind
of downturn but ultimately this is a big
platform form wearables in general which
is gets us into a whole nother topic
which is augmented virtual reality but
this is kind of the segue into it where
the watch becomes gangbusters and when
it can stand on its own right now it
needs to be paired with a phone and once
they figure the battery out it's
probably a few years down the road but
you'll see a standalone watch and I
think at that point that's when some of
the we really dick tracy you won't need
the phone in your pocket to you won't
need the phone people want different
screen sizes for different times of the
day and that's the that's the approach
that's what's holding it back there
right now right that connection to the
phone i think so i think you know
there's the app piece some of that can
stall with a new operating system that
it just came out with so the quality of
the apps are gonna start to improve but
when you think about this really going
vertical yeah it's gonna probably take
the watch as a standalone it do you like
it do you use it actively I do I mean I
use it every day and the times when I
don't charge it I fall asleep too early
and forget to put it I'm kind of
frustrated I've bought several charges
now to make sure I have one so I'm in
the camp who actually likes it but
there's certain things that I'm really
passionate or your initial I think
you're really interesting way to think
of it when you first started publishing
about this saying that there's been an
attached rate and it's sort of an
accessory to the iphone a certain
percentage of users just as a certain
percentage of users will use a bluetooth
wireless headset a certain percentage of
users of the iphone will have the
ultimate iphone accessory the watch what
do you think that do you think that's
still a right way to look at it and use
what do you think the attached where it
is i think it is the right way to look
at it and the most recent quarter was
around ten or twelve percent something
like that because they sold about that's
the the current tatra i'm sorry it's
about six percent is about six percent
so that there is a attached right side
to it i think at the end of the day is
that you got to look at this as a
consumer technology play once it
doesn't have to deal with the attached
piece of it the pairing part that's when
it goes mainstream and I think we're a
few look at the numbers of Fitbit sold
for example I mean we mentioned were
both wearing job but well Fitbit
dominates that they've done Apple of
course entering this quarter IDC numbers
Apple is entered in isn't it has a very
big play in the first quarter that the
devices were out there but in garmin
another really interesting company that
has it sells a lot of these things but
there's clearly a big market there for
wearables there is a big market i'm
curious maybe a quick on a scale one to
ten what you think of your Fitbit the
job on the job when you know I'll speak
for Carol what I will my work wife my
New York were quite um we're both
irritated by it all the time we both
were every single day I could tell you
my first the first time I got it I mean
I went through three or four or five
because they kept breaking down okay
well that was frustrating but Corey to
appoint you you wanted a we want to work
and what's happening is this is one
segment that they're really going after
which is really just kind of monitoring
your fitness and the gamification of
that there's also like targets doing is
there to point into a lot of their
employees and and kind of for health and
wellness what so I think that's a
segment itself and then there's a
wearable Sigma that's got to be a huge
segment we just had another guest on
this week talking about you know if you
can get corporations you come in you
become a new employee get your ID you
get you fit on a wellness wellness
program where they go to corporations
and they sell 30,000 at a moment to it
the all the employees of a company do
you see that the norm some day where you
become a new employee and you get some
kind of wearable that's tracking your
health I think you do by the the level
does a sophistication of the wearable is
gonna go up dramatically and so I think
what you have on there isn't gonna cut
it a few years from now